[Music]
this is Major I'm on safe I'm going in
you are the first of your kind but
you're not invulnerable maybe next time
you can design me better everyone around
me they feel connected to something
connected to something
[Music]
but ie you were dying
we saved you and now you see the others
[Music]
I'm impressed trust me
you know I have a past
I'll find out who I was
everything they told you was a lie
who are you they did not save your life
they stole it
oh god I know vomit on you I'm gonna
comfortable stuff
I'll see mama beans oh she who made the
anime oh came to visit us in production
to see that world imagined it's pretty
spectacular scale of it is so baked in
from the beginning it's very true that
anime Roberta is really a visionary that
very good thanks Carla it's called she's
incredible it's great to start from
something that inspires you
this experience has been like nothing
else I've ever had before
Scarlett Johansson photos the segment
intimately but I sort of says oh yeah
but you're not as good at the holdup
another girl HIO just something we
created a universe that people haven't
seen before
Tommy's story tell me